I got Craig hi-yah
the channel called pistol shrimp it's
still shrimp never seen this channel for
my right eye but a lot of people sent
this video over to me Oh
DM Lord oh my god I've been wanting to
see this because I saw the harry and
voldemort one and it was hilarious
something tells me this is a crossover
between Beauty and the Beast and
Voldemort I think that that's what the
impression that's my brain the brain
Daman lining the cogs moving towards
that yeah her director rubella
[Music]
you must be careful
currents the light I'm a Harry Potter
fan so it rains a lot to me
look at how he is the one going to break
this bad
so you can fool no there's no
conceivable yes
[Music]
chalo be gentle kind sweet
don't go show me this smile
[Music]
No
oh wow I actually got two into my god
okay I will say though at the end I feel
like it should have been more powerful
like a Nevada Colorado and you don't
know what's happening like you don't
know whose voice it is it could be
anyone that could have died it's like
negative thing remind me I'm [ __ ]
Baltimore dude why are you kidding me I
will say like the way they blend it in
Lord Voldemort into this whole trail
it'll look pretty rather long yeah yeah
really good you look like a wooden G
house real trailer right here was it
like an the only thing I wished was they
I mean this is a lot I can't do anything
of what they just did like I said I
can't
yeah but if I were to make one request
is that they could have had it was if
they were able to somehow Alou that she
was Hermione and now that would have
been cool doubt of it that would have
been a nice little like twist like maybe
even throw in a little bit at the end
like just a little teaser like oh who
are you whatever like her mom comes out
with her [ __ ] wand
yeah very potter like Gryffindor dear
you know oh so they were going for
otherwise it would've just been confused
me and real trade-rape vines man more
than awesome yeah I feel like prey upon
does not get enough credit for him what
he did with Voldemort
yeah because Voldemort was already like
think about like you know when Robert
has those cats that were to do I like
there's all this like hype noodle clunk
is going to be in yes yeah and same
thing with Voldemort was how is
Voldemort gonna be portrayed are they
gonna do a good enough job yeah the guys
are good it up Jonathan bird man yeah he
does this amazing - like I was watching
I was just watching him in here I'm like
you know what like I feel like no one
ever really credited ray vines for how
great of a job he did is Voldemort no
yes maybe not enough credit you know but
he did yeah he did really yeah excellent
job it's hard to I feel like the casting
in that moon
in the series of Harry Potter we do
spot-on like I really was into every
character reading the books and then
watching the movies it's like yes that's
how I saw this character is like perfect
and this is great promotion for Beauty
and the Beast in it because it's a
mining is having a fun Lee another huge
film first huge film from Harry Potter
in the lot yeah but I see you're getting
work though because she was just a
beautiful talented actress I know some
people over at studios who said that
Beauty and the Beast is a phenomenal
film really Oh can't we just be in your
attire it's phenomenal and a little look
at yeah it does look very visually
appealing there's a lot of beautiful
visuals so I would definitely I'm
definitely gonna watch it as well but I
want to see more of kiss I love these
like trailer mashup yeah yeah do that I
want to see more pistols from Swart
dated obviously don't work as hard as I
do it's creating watching their video
and talking about how would they could
have done with it yeah I wasn't even
working that hard nobody I know right
just use that it's really difficult
compared to with it they use is nothing
yeah okay I subscribe to pistol shrimp
be certified to this new videos every
other Sunday from these mofos subscribe
to reject channel real regen they made a
star gainer your shower in there go
subscribe to her channel why not he's
got some mediocre videos very that's a
compliment
yeah compared to what they actually are
it's the drip mediocre you don't even
you know you shouldn't even go to my gym
yeah there's really no big one reason
don't bother you know just stay over
here she's studying psychology so we're
working on a thing called reverse
psychology velour secret it's not gonna
work if you tell them Gregory House
clothes wear the dough when they are is
gonna really slap I just said it is like
fake hitting